many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism does being a
stoic mean that I can't have empathy
this is a really great question and I
think it's one that we need to be
careful in answering to make a number of
needed distinctions for those who don't
want to wait around for that discussion
there is a very simple answer no being a
stoic does not mean that you cannot have
empathy as a matter of fact there are
plenty of people who either
self-identify as Stoics or we can call
Stoics because they are classical
representatives who did display what we
nowadays call empathy before we
discussed why it is that yes a stoic can
in fact feel and exercise empathy
towards other people we should think a
little bit about some of the assumptions
that are going into this and and one
thing to clarify from the beginning not
everybody means the same thing by
empathy and we'll talk about that in
just a moment
but why are people so concerned about
this why would they think that being a
stoic would automatically preclude that
I think that one of the reasons is a
misunderstanding of what it means to be
a stoic there's often a distinction made
between lowercase s stoicism which is a
character trait or way of being it's
sort of a popular conception and then
there's actual uppercase stoicism what
it is that stoic philosophers actually
taught and what it is that Stoics in the
present actually teach and practice
themselves today and I think the the
more generic popular misconception of
lowercase s stoicism does in fact rule
out empathy you want to detach yourself
as much as possible from other people
and their feelings or their suffering
but that's not
actually real stoicism genuine stoicism
says that we ought to be concerned about
others but we ought not to be concerned
in a sort of willy-nilly arbitrary way
we should do so in a rational way now
speaking about empathizing in a rational
way I think is going to throw a lot of
people because they have the mistaken
assumption that somehow rationality and
feeling affect emotion are two totally
separate things and they have nothing to
do with each other there are some
viewpoints that hold that stoicism is
not one of them as a matter of fact the
ideal stoic sage the person that we
rarely see but also you know what it is
that a person in development or working
on themselves ought to tend towards is
going to feel some things towards other
people these are called the you path I
the good emotions if you like or good
effects and empathy in the way that many
people understand it today could in fact
be among those effects I'd like to
mention just a few examples from classic
stoic texts and thinkers so Epictetus in
talking about why people do things wrong
and whether we should you know get upset
with them he says that perhaps we would
be better off and it's translated
feeling pity and that term there allows
can also be translated as compassion and
I think that it has some of the same
semantic range as empathy particularly
sense
Epictetus suggests that we you know
might want to think about why the person
is is doing the wrongheaded things that
they're doing that may make us angry or
may make us feel sad or produce other
emotions and that is in a certain sense
to empathize with them he also mentions
at another point when it comes to
grieving it's perfectly fine to sit
there and put your arm around somebody
and say oh this is really bad he says
just don't groan inwardly so that's sort
of a rational approach to it Marcus
Aurelius throughout the
patience as many similar things I think
you can just dig around and there you're
gonna find him saying you know think
about what you would feel like if you
were in that situation and then you know
maybe don't be so judgy right and so
when we get down to it we see these are
just a few examples there are many
examples of Stoics actually counselling
or displaying well we would nowadays
call by this slippery term empathy bring
this to a close there is no
incompatibility between being a stoic
whether in the sense of being the ideal
develops age or being somebody who's
committed to stoicism and practicing it
and trying to move towards that there's
no contradiction or incompatibility
between that and empathy understood in
the proper sense as a matter of fact you
can actually make a case that some
version of empathy is probably going to
be integral to the stoic life if you
found this answer helpful for you then
please share it with others who might
benefit from it this work is entirely
supported by crowdfunding on my patreon
site so if you find it valuable consider
becoming a supporter at patreon.com
slash Sadler